for protestors across America a
hard-fought moment of justice today I
filed an amended complaint the charges
the charges former Minneapolis police
officer Derek Chavan with murder in the
second degree or the death of George
Floyd Hennepin County Attorney Michael
Freeman and I have filed a complaint it
charges police officer King Lane and tau
with aiding and abetting murder in the
second degree
a felony offense Derek Chauvin whose
knee was on George Floyd's neck for
nearly nine minutes now faces a more
serious charge this footage shows the
role the other three officers played the
role that they'll now be arrested for
their own boss the chief of Minneapolis
Police had already said their silence
and failure to intervene made them
complicit every human being who has any
humanity in them are horrified when they
see on this video their only question is
why weren't those police officers
horrified and so the family's statement
to those police officers are they
just as guilty for the death of George
Florida as officer Chauvin they all
participated this development is what
George Floyd's family was so desperate
for as his grieving son made a painful
visit to the site of his father's death
every night with my family
Thank You justice my father and know no
man or woman sister should without their
fathers
we went justice for what's going on
right now this personal tragedy was the
trigger for what's now happening across
the world in America protests have
become less violent but the rage over
police brutality against black Americans
is still burning there's also growing
anger over president Trump's handling of
the crisis his threat of military
intervention in the demonstrations has
been publicly defied by his own defense
secretary Donald Trump says he has done
more for the black community than any
president since Abraham Lincoln it's not
a view shared by protesters justice will
be a small victory here but real
systemic change is the ultimate prize
Amanda Walker Sky News washing